Speaker 1: All right, let's hear from a few
more people via discord, you can go to David
Pakman dotcom discord joined the discussion.
Twelve or thirteen thousand of you have done
that. I'm selling you nothing other than a free,
good time on the discord. Let's talk to oh,
this is interesting. It's someone from my native
Bueno Situs who goes by the name B. Is that that's
all you want to tell us? Just the letter B?
Speaker 5:
Hi, can you hear me, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: Awesome. Hi, yeah, I'm from
Buenos Aires as well, so I actually I
also share a Jewish background like you, though
I never moved to the States. I thought that was
interesting to mention. Beautiful.
Um, yeah. So what I see a lot is that
it's very easy for someone like Ben Shapiro to
claim to be objective and do something that is.
Relatively that I mean, making objective
statements about problems sees using the left
and then he completely failed to mention
anything that goes on in the right that
could be problematic. And I think that's one
of the main issues why it's so hard for me to.
B, don't you think that also happens with a left
leg, which can be pretty good at complaining about
things that are just objectively wrong
in the in the right, but then fail to
complain about some of the things that have
left us? That just doesn't make a lot of sense.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is a this is a
basic cognitive bias that people have,
and that includes failing to see your blind
spots while being very easily able to point
out those of the other side or your political
adversaries or whatever the case may be,
confirmation bias, looking for confirmation
for your preexisting beliefs rather than fairly
evaluating them? I think absolutely. That's that's
a cognitive bias. And step one in fighting against
it is being aware of it. That's just you. If
you're not aware of it, you're not going to have
a good shot at dealing with that and facing that.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I agree, though, since you agree
with this part of the other question, um, don't
you feel like at times your channel and I'm not
saying that the information that you provide
is not valuable because I do think it is very
valuable. Don't you feel like sometimes you
could point out some things that have left
us more precisely? I feel like if I have to
find out about something that the left us
that I really don't like, I have to find out about
that from a right leaning channel and from yours.
Speaker 1: I think that I mean, listen, I don't
do as well as as I could write it. There's more
to aspire to. But I have made an effort to point
out when I think the left is failing to actually
deal with issues correctly or sometimes even
failing to be progressive. And there are instances
where, while I generally agree with the left on
tax policy, there are sometimes just economic
misunderstandings. That groupthink takes over
and something gets popular on the left. And it's
like when you think about it, it's not really
great economic policy. Or sometimes the left
will go too far on issues relating to, you know,
authoritarianism over language or whatever the
case may be. I mean, if if the critique is I don't
do it enough or well enough, yes, I welcome that
critique. I will say I'm aware of it. And I make
an effort to say, hey, here's an issue on which
the right is 90 percent wrong, but the left is
20 percent wrong. And here's that 20 percent. And
let's understand it and let's deal with it.
Speaker 5: Well, I definitely appreciate you
acknowledging the feedback means a lot to me,
and, yeah, I was I was just wondering, given
that I live so far away from where you are and I
am I am basically a different audience. That and
your mainstream audience. I was wondering if you
actually had any questions for someone like me.
Speaker 1: You know, I really don't. Other
than what part of situs do you live in?
Oh, OK, I have cousins there, beautiful area.
Speaker 5: Yes, vertical. Well,
thanks a lot for having me.
Speaker 1: OK, thank you.
Appreciate it. We're on a slight delay, but
I really appreciate the call and hope to
hear from you again. All right. There's B. from
Buenos Aires, Argentina, a very exciting phone